بينما توحد المعارضه التركيه قواها
لمواجهه رئيس اردوغان في الانتخابات
المقبله هناك من يهدد هذا التحالف ويخلط
اوراقه انه محرم ان جاء ابرز وجوه
المعارضه ورجالها في انتخابات 2018 نفس
اردوغان على الرئاسه لكنه اعترف بخسارته
عبر رساله صحفيه ان جاء وقبل اسابيع عمل
الاستحقاق الدستوري اعلن ترشحه منفردا تحت
الوان حزبه الوطن ترشح الخطيب المثير
للجدل اعتبر نبا غير صار للمعارضه فمحرم
انجى لديه قدره على جذب اصوات نخبي حزبي
الشعب والخير ابرز التشكيلات المعارضه
التركيه
بترشحه ووفقا لمحللين يمكن ان يلعب دور
المفسد ويقود الانتخابات الى جوله ثانيه
هذه الجوله ان لم تضر باردوغان فستفسد
الامر على تحالف المعارضه تحالف يدخل
الصراع بسباق مع الزمان لاقناع محرم ان
جاء على الانسحاب